hello everybody and welcome to rational
science
[Music]
today we have a great day first i want
to say that i was in london for the past
couple days so that's why i had to
postpone the class
hopefully
this sunday
will be normal
okay uh so let's get started here and
here's a rundown of what we're gonna be
doing today okay
i'm gonna look at what is a concept okay
and i'm gonna
beat up a little bit on the electric
universe
on the flat earthers
on the
oh
on the flat earthers uh the flat
universers
and uh there we have a definition of
what all those words mean idiocy
idiotic idiopathic
uh any of those you know they it's got
to do with word idiot we got a lot of
ideas yeah it's an individual with big
ideas
see when you have a normal idea it's an
idea but when you have an idea
well then uh we know that you know i
have a big idea and that's more or less
where all these people stand okay we're
gonna go with the science critic later
on uh also he's got
big ideas as well
okay
and finally we're going to open flora
for some questions and comments
first the ones that people made since
last time and then
whatever people asked today
okay so let's get started here and uh
before i can uh
begin let's begin at the beginning begin
to begin beginning
to begin
okay so here it is and a fellow says the
following he says uh
bill spends half the time insulting his
seven loyal viewers not very
compassionate it's called gaslighting no
school would tolerate such behavior from
a teacher
and guest lighting comes from
it was a play originally then they made
a movie in uh great britain another one
four years later in uh hollywood in fact
angry birdman won her no
no
her oscar for gaslight
and it has to do with a fellow who uh
tries to drive his uh wife crazy to
uh get some jewels and some money okay
and so uh he makes her believe
you know what uh
what is not real and that's essentially
there you see the definition manipulate
someone by psychological means into
doubting their own sanity okay so that's
essentially what gaslighting is you're
saying i'm gaslighting i'm leading you
to believe what you're what is not real
and uh somehow i'm misleading you
fooling you or whatever
okay um
so let's look at a little bit of that
first of all here's another person who
said the following says
galileo was
ridiculed okay
and yeah he proposed that there were
four other moons that no one had seen
before he saw him through his telescope
and
the bishops the cardinals of rome
said well they're not in the bible
in the book in the good book so we don't
believe you you know and so they
ridicule him
and all i want to tell you is you know
in so-called science physics
even in you could say in philosophy a
lot of that gets mixed up with physics
you know for the last 3000 years people
have been laughing at each other half
the world laughs at the other half you
have the uh hindus they laugh at the
buddhists the buddhists laughed at the
muslims the muslims at the christians
the christians had all of them
and they all laughed back you know it's
very common to ridicule and laugh
at those people who don't have
opinions or theories like yours
and so this is very common and nothing
has changed in the last three thousand
years you know here let me give you some
examples okay let's uh go through that
so that we make sure we
we cover all we cover all these bases
here's the first one okay
this is mr john baez and he created the
crackpot index at uc riverside it's been
there for the last what 25 years
says
these are just three of the items uh
taken out of that crackpot index some of
you are familiar with it first one there
number 11 says 10 points for each claim
that quantum mechanics is fundamentally
misguided
then the next one says 10 points for
arguing that while the current
well-established theory predicts
phenomena correctly it doesn't explain
why they occur or fails to provide a
mechanism that's on there yeah you would
think that that is supposed to be what
physics is about
and this gentleman you know he's uh he's
there at the uc riverside he's a
professor there and he says that
apparently in his mind that's or what he
learned in school that's not part of the
scientific method okay
are we okay there yeah
okay we're getting these uh we're
getting errors uh from youtube as usual
i don't know why
anyways uh and then the last one there
are 10 points for each claim that
special or general relativity are
fundamentally misguided again
what i want you to notice here is that
this is from ucr uh
university of uh california riverside
okay
and
you know what i want you to understand
is you're paying taxes
and riverside is partly maintained by
government funds
so you're paying for these people to
have on their website officially for the
last 25 years
uh these uh
you know this this crackpot index and
they'll use it against you and they'll
ridicule you and you're you're paying
for to to get ridiculed
you know maybe you don't agree with
general relativity with space-time maybe
you don't agree with quantum mechanics
and here they're saying if you don't
agree well
you're a poo poo
that's essentially it
so you're paying for that so think about
that yeah they do ridicule you in
science so if a little kid comes up to
that guy and asks how do two magnets
attract each other
he says you're a crackpot kid you're
asking the wrong question
yeah exactly and we'll get to that in
fact that's the subject matter of the
site of the science critic here's
another one okay so that you can collect
them okay here's number two
it says john rennie you know uh and he
talks about the laws of credibility now
it's important to know that john rennie
is a big shot up there he created the
crack uh the i'm sorry the stack
exchange
and you can look it up that's a
primary scientific or physics
mathematical physics right site that
people check regularly and he's also in
charge of some magazines he was editor
in several magazines so he's he's a big
shot up there he's got uh censorship
power and this is what he says okay he
says scientists don't always know best
about matters of science but they're
more likely to be right than the critics
who make that argument
so if you're a critic and you criticize
official dumb you know mainstream
well then
you're not gonna be right okay they're
gonna be right
and he's got these corollaries to the
law of credibility and it's the first
one says the first job of any scientific
fraud is to persuade the public that
science is itself unscientific
it turns out that you know they have all
these irrational explanations uh from
quantum mechanics general relativity and
uh string theory they tell you in your
face
the the mainstream mainstreamers they
tell you they themselves do not
understand them but here they say that
if you criticize and say that's
unscientific because it doesn't make any
sense
uh then they say that you're a fraud
and then the second corollary to the law
of credibility is any iconoclast with a
scientifically unorthodox view okay you
might be a dissident right who reminds
you that galileo was persecuted to
ain't galileo
okay so there are no more galileos okay
that's what he's saying what's
interesting that he talks about the law
of credibility
and the corollaries of credibility
and credibility you know i think it's
got to do with um what you believe in
sounds like uh religion to me it doesn't
sound like anything related to science
it's like authority yeah and tradition
and democracy you know how many people
voted for your theory so yeah none of
that has anything to do with science but
this is what ronnie was
brainwashed to believe in high school
and college
okay
but this is how they trash you they
insult you they ridicule you they're
allowed to do it but here this file says
bill
you're a bully look how you're treating
all all your followers or the nonprofit
the visitors and so on
okay i think you just built up too much
resentment for all the
for all the times you were called the
crackpot well no i'm just being i'm just
playing the game the way everybody else
plays it so please don't pick on me if
you're going to do something go to
riverside and take ask them to take the
uh
crackpot index out of there because
you're paying taxes those taxes are used
to support the university and they're
using that to trash you because you
don't believe in quantum mechanics or
general relativity that's where you
should start not beat up on me a little
old me i'm a nobody in comparison okay
and here's a final uh example here's uh
john horgan he's a
newsman he uh he's he also teaches at
one of the universities out there
but he's a reporter primarily he writes
i think for the new york times and other
prominent magazines he says science and
common sense should be compatible he
argues that modern
physics mathematical physics somehow is
unintuitive you know it's not it doesn't
make sense
and here we have a so-called physicist
mathematical physicist okay from
stanford university and he says the
following he answers as follows he says
who's common sense john horgans
admittedly a non-scientist i presume
instead of despecting
railing against what he plainly does not
understand oregon would do better to
take a few courses in algebra calculus
etcetera etcetera
modern science is difficult and often
counterintuitive where intuition and
common sense failed they had to create
new forms of intuition mainly through
the use of abstract mathematics when
common sense fails uncommon sense must
be created
okay
that was his answer
so yeah all these people trash ridicule
and uh belittle anyone who
comes up against them they have the
power because they have all these think
tanks every university is filled with
them they receive millions
i would say even a billion dollars if
you look at all the universities on the
planet they receive money from
governments from private uh
individuals who donate money to them you
have all these centers uh the princeton
center there you have mit caltech
they're all over the planet in russia
and china everyone they all believe in
the same thing or at every university
and the planet
and they will trash you
they will ridicule you if you dare raise
a finger against general relativity
quantum mechanics or string theory which
they admittedly you know they admit it
admit that they do not understand that
they cannot explain
i mean it is kind of suspicious that
they would that they would ridicule
people instead of i mean even you take
flat earthers seriously enough to debate
them yeah but they don't they don't they
don't even you know they they will not
even uh bother with electric universes
they would not analyze what they were
saying is dehumanizing in a way you at
least take other people's consider
criticisms to into consideration like
okay maybe maybe there's something to
this or maybe you think it's dumb but
you investigate it and challenge it you
don't just right right i i answer the
questions as best as i can you know uh
so if a flat earther comes over i'll i
might trash him
but i will answer
but i will answer him
yeah if it's an important issue i'll
raise it i'll bring it up here i'll put
it under flat earth i'll ridicule the
guy but i will answer the other people
they do not even you know they don't
even bother answering they don't even
take them seriously okay but they they
have better things to do like
indoctrinate more people yeah i guess
they do you know they have the time but
my point is you know ridicule and
bashing has been around for three
thousand years part of the game if you
do not have the stomach for it
i strongly suggest that you do not
abandon your uh job at the uh bus stop
you know cleaning latrines i mean you
shouldn't do that if you had something
for it anyway yeah i mean if you're
having somewhere you don't you know
you're in the wrong field this is a
trashing ridiculing field
and if you don't know that to the point
because if there's no point you're just
trashing them well again you know uh
after
20 years that i've been doing this uh
none of those i've got a very thick skin
so none of that hurts me anymore but it
should hurt you if it does hurt you you
have a problem you got to see your your
shrink okay you're in the wrong field so
here here i'll give you how we treat
people here okay here it is
this is the motto of the bill gates
school of physics we teach with a
baseball bat
okay
so if
you say something which is dumb
uh
probably
i guess
yeah well the baseball bat's too long so
i use my uh dough roller okay so uh just
be aware you know yeah we're not gonna
be kind to you if you bring nonsense
over you okay
so
just
just make sure you feel at home you know
if i say something that offends you uh
just take it in a different way that's
the way i look at it we do not insult
anyone we treat everyone with the
respect that they deserve
okay
okay moving on here folks we have a
fella says he says
physics and measurement go together like
bread and butter measuring objects puts
them in their place
accurately accurately we got a
snap collector yeah yeah he says
measurement is science so if you measure
a table like that little fellow there
is doing he says you're you're a
scientist okay so he says that
measurement is science
and yeah we that's when we bring the
door
we uh educate them the right way we
learn them okay we learn
okay so here uh we have a little bit of
some answers uh what uh some of the
things that physics does not
do these are not
activities
of physics okay so in case you use any
of these activities you do some of these
activities you think these have belonged
to physics
here we correct you okay we learn you
properly all right
okay so here yes we have observe we do
not observe we do not gawk okay which is
what all these people are doing on the
right okay
we do not do experiments
we don't do experiments in science yeah
you heard it right let me repeat it
because some people say well he must
have misspoken no no we do not do
experiments in science anyone can do an
experiment not to learn anything from it
and he thinks he's a scientist that's
not the way it works i don't say it
differently
i'd say these are part of science but
it's not the crucial part of science
okay they're like a preamble to science
yeah we're saying that well the way i
like to put it is this way that's the
way i put it there's the detective
and there's a prosecutor okay
now they have two different jobs
okay
the the
prosecutor is the person who says you're
innocent until proven guilty okay and he
goes through the motions of explaining
why he thinks you're guilty
the detective works exactly in the
opposite direction he says you're not
off the hook until we can verify your
alibi until then you are a suspect you
are considered a suspect still
okay so they work exactly in opposite
ways
meaning the detective goes out and does
all his job he looks for evidence
fingerprints whatever he found out there
the gun etc right
he gives all that to the prosecutor
he is not a scientist he did the
investigation he did all the hard work
he is not a scientist the scientist the
prosecutor the guy who has to explain it
at the conference
yeah he's got to make sense of it and
present it to the jury in this case
presented to in the conference he says
this is how how the universe works for
example
you're basically saying anyone can ask
the question but to answer it because
anyone can drop the pen
but explain why it drops that's the
science that's one issue the other one
is research is not science
okay research is not science you can
research all you want it doesn't mean
you came up with something
it's the guy who presents it and says
let me explain it to you
that's the scientist but to do research
and not make any progress not have
learned anything so what you did
research so what have you studied so
what have you observed so what if you
did experiments and did not learn
anything
that's the detective
okay i'd still say it's part of science
because it's the whole process
i i add that to the process but it's not
the crucial part if you just do that
you're not doing science we chop it off
here if you want to go clean yeah you
want to make it as clean as possible
here we say only the prosecutor the guy
who presents a theory is the scientist
that's the only guy that's a scientist
the other guy who did all the hard work
he's not a sign he's just a lab worker
he's a gopher he's a gopher hey bell boy
okay yeah
it doesn't work i'll put it together so
i just want you to know what we say here
okay uh anyways none of these collect
data device equations predict making
predictions that's called an astrologer
okay that's not science scientists we
don't present evidence okay uh we assume
not not in the case of prosecutors you
know the
regular law people present evidence
uh in science we don't we just explain
without evidence because evidence is
used to persuade and we do not persuade
in science
because that has to do with religion
we're convincing you with twisting your
arm okay we do not test theories we
don't verify or falsify theories we
never fake anything no falsifying in
science okay we don't prove we don't
know knowledge has nothing to do with
science okay we don't believe we explain
uh we don't per se convince convert or
recruit we don't invent
technology has nothing to do with
science we don't form clubs associations
you know
groups with other people i mean you can
if you want congregations that's got to
do with religion well just because it
doesn't mean you are a scientist right
right and that's my point and then we do
not give prizes okay so none of those
have anything to do with being a
scientist or a physicist
and uh one step further now we move one
step further and we say science does not
use any of these terms
okay
we do not use the word force we do not
use the word field energy mass time none
of those words
without defining it rigorously no no
even if you define it rigorously because
none of those words can be defined
rigorously that's your assumption no no
that's my knowledge i know for a while
okay none of those words belong in
science why because let me tell you what
the origin of those words are the reason
you learned all these words probably in
high school probably in college okay is
because the mathematicians
put them in your head
okay they shoved them into your nose
holes
and your holes
shove them into your nose holes and what
happened with that is that you memorize
them and now you move these things
around the problem here is that you
treat them as physical objects and as
the subject of today will be
these are all concepts and you cannot
treat a concept as an object that's
where the problem is
okay so if you use any of these terms we
will use our dough roller on you okay
you can't make your case with any of
these words okay that's where it starts
okay and you will find a couple words
there one is ether at the bottom
left there
and electricity in the top middle there
okay
ether and electricity are not physical
objects and people say electricity moves
current
moves runs whatever flows
you can't use that language in science
and no this is not semantics okay people
say bill you're doing semantic you're
doing word wizardry we're trying to
teach you how to talk in physics
okay and it's very hard because you
learn something different
in uh high school and college and so so
you're so used to saying the current
flows that's like saying the river flows
now the river already is flowing because
river means water that flows
so you can't say the water that flows
flows that's what you're saying when you
say the river flows and when you say
electricity flows or current flows
you're saying current is what what is
current current is if you go with the uh
official you know the mainstream
electro it's the motion of electrons
from one atom to another that's what it
is if that's what you believe you might
have a different version okay no problem
but in general people think of current
as the flow of electron beads from one
atom to another the electron bead is the
object a little ball there that's what
you got to think of it as and it's
flowing it's going from one atom to
another that flow is called electricity
you cannot say electricity flows or
current flows you can say the electron
flows not that the electron flow is
flowing yeah you can't say the the
movement is moving so we're trying to
teach you how to talk and people don't
like to be taught how to talk because
they say i've been saying current flows
for years yeah because that's what they
taught you in high school well i think
what you the way you just laid it out is
more
convincing or more it's it's clearer for
the listener than just saying don't use
these words
it's better to explain look what are you
saying right now you're saying that the
motion moved yeah what does that mean
you're saying that the electrum flow
flows yes yeah
and the electron can flow faster maybe
or change direction yeah but that's not
what they're saying
and they get into that bad habit and
what you're doing is using words of
mathematical physics other those words
that you just saw belong to math math
deals with numbers
and with operations on numbers right
that's math and what they did they said
well how do we apply this how do we make
any sense of the world
if we we don't introduce math into that
world and measure and analyze it
mathematically and that's where
we have this religion known as
mathematical physics came into being and
they had to create words to be able to
give some physical interpretations to
the equations that's when they created
the word force the word mass the word
energy all these
irrational terms which are not only
undefined but even if you were to define
them perfectly they wouldn't make any
sense their notions are nounified verbs
yeah because they can't criticize they
concretize them or however you say that
like
implies foreign but when you say the
force moved something yeah no the thing
that that moves something moves
something well you can't the concept
that we used to explain that yeah
because all you said
is push pushed it that's all you said or
pulled it
you can't say that you gotta say you
know what is the physical object that
did the pushing then you can talk about
force and then you don't need force at
all because now you mentioned the hand
and the box and you said my hand pushed
the box we're down we don't need the
word force but when you say a force
came up against the box
now it means you brought too many beers
i mean i keep telling you i think robots
and programs could do better physics
than most people
if you have to define everything so
rigorously they would find all the kinks
in the in the theory i think some of the
programmers up there might understand
that argument
okay so here's one fellow and he uses
ether and he says there's nothing
irrational about the ether ah it's uh
nothing mystical it's a fluid
okay you mean like water you know it's
uh and what is water well water is uh
you know um
it's a fluid just a bunch of atoms right
it's a fluid he says ether is only
irrational if you believe it's made of
particles
what is a fluid made out of i mean if
it's atoms not particles come on
yeah a fluid is made what do you think
an ether is
you got to tell me first of all because
you're introducing me there but there
you have the ether it's a bunch of
particles and that's what they say well
there's two versions one version is that
the ether is space a space and ether are
synonyms they're identical and another
one is that ether is within space okay
those are the two versions that are out
there and uh so the question here in
that case that you see there you see all
these little dust that's the ether the
black stuff is space so it's ether
within space
and what is moving there could be one of
two it's either
a wave
moving through the ether or it's the
ether itself which is vibrating and we
have all these versions out there of
what the ether is what a wave is and all
that stuff okay so you have to be very
specific
about what it is that you're moving the
physical object is absolutely crucial
you need to identify it well it's also
the base assumption from which you
explain things so
the properties of it have to be
rigorously defined so that we can get
all the
the the because when you make an
assumption especially a base one you get
a lot of
resulting
i guess like logic from it like for
example yours when you say all atoms are
connected by ropes yeah that's an
assumption we don't know this we're just
assuming it yeah but once you assume
that
when you follow that line of logic you
get all these tangents of what that
means yeah yeah and it's the same thing
here you have to really rigorously
define that assumption because if you
just change a little bit of it you're
going to get way different yeah it's
like in a golf swing that's one issue
that's one issue but the other issue is
that you have to identify the object and
there's only one way to identify the
object is put it in front of our eyes so
we know what you're referring to when
you say ether so you have to point to it
and say look this is the ether if you're
going to treat it as a physical object
if you're going to vibrate it okay and
there's a difference between vibrating
all the ether in the universe you know
as one block as a single thing
okay
and and vibrating a teeny region of the
ether and saying well the wave is the
vibration of the ether no if you're
going to vibrate ether it's the whole
thing if you're going to use a little
portion of the ether you better call it
something else that's not the ether the
palm is not the same thing as the hand
palm is a region of the hand if you're
going to use a region of the ether and
you can't say the ether vibrates and
that's what
light is the vibration of the ether no
but if you're vibrating these are you're
vibrating the entire universe as a
single thing
if the ether is the collection of all
these
regions you could say then vibrating the
ether would mean vibrating the
collection of all the regions yeah you
get a you got to separate the
logic you just apply rigorous logic to
everyone's words and a lot of things are
real a lot of these people are not
logical that's the problem well i don't
think they just i don't think they get
to the bottom of what they're saying
themselves they're saying and here you
have a definition of the ether two two
definition one is uh from the dictionary
upper regions of space you know the uh
greeks essentially called it ether which
i think means air it's it was the god
god's air okay the air that was outside
the earth that they couldn't touch or
see okay that was the eater it's a
special type of air and what is the air
made out of rope particles okay made out
of units
special
and then uh the other one at the bottom
postulated medium for the propagation of
light and again uh either either the
ether is
what is vibrating or the light is
passing through the ether
it's the medium through which this
whatever light is passes through the
light is either being carried by the
earth or it is the ether's perturbation
so you got to identify which of the two
it is is light the vibration of the
ether which is what the 19th century
believed or is like something else
separate from the ether that goes
through the ether as if like a fish
through the water but i guess but
along the same lines
it kind of also applies to the black
hole and these kind of things where
there's so many versions of it you can't
just criticize because like ah that's
not the one i was talking about
so you can run around yeah not that one
not that one you're thinking of someone
else's black hole not my ether so when
in doubt when in doubt what we do is we
go to the sources and the original
source were the um but there's many
sources no no yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying the original source you could say
is the greeks which also inherited that
probably from the east somewhere i don't
think the greeks were the originators
but they used that same concept the
notion of the ether and it was
resuscitated more or less by descartes
okay rene descartes and this is what he
had to say about the ether what's that
ugly
yeah
space is a plenum okay
and he says uh and what is a plenum was
a space or all space every part of which
is full of matter
okay so uh again we're talking about a
bunch of particles that's that was his
notion he said what field space is the
ether okay
and uh and then you see that other
paragraph there and all this it comes
from edmund whitaker who wrote a history
of the theories of the ether and this
this is a
statement taken from
renee okay it says the vehicle of light
is composed of a closely packed
assemblage of what global globules uh
spherical particles whose size is very
small compared to the bodies we see on
earth so what are we talking about
little particles that's what the ether
is it's comprised of all these little
particles the globules are pressed in
contact with each other and move
outwards it is the transmission of this
pressure which constitutes light so in
the case of uh mr descartes he thought
that light was itself the vibration of
the ether and that's what all the 19th
century also who came later right also
believed they always thought that light
itself was the vibration of the ether
but again it's the wrong notion because
if the ether is what fills all of space
you cannot say that vibration of the
ether is light because you got to look
at the whole object the object is the
whole shebang
line pull a little bit out of it and say
it's a vibration of the ether no it's a
vibration of a bunch of particles
that constitute the ether then you can
say that but not that either you kind of
have the similar situation where when
you're explaining light with the rope
hypothesis you just take a chunk of the
hole and i call that a and i call it a
rope
yeah but i don't care
you in the end i guess are taking a
chunk of the entire i am i absolutely i
am but
when you say rope i'm referring only
what's between two atoms i'm saying this
is like
so but you can't do that with the ether
you can't say well there's everything
and it's also the little thing that i'm
gonna vibrate that makes it you can't do
this confuses people yeah and that's
where the problem is with all these
people well just in case we have some
reinforcement here we have these people
robert boyle uh the ether consists of
subtle particles uh
huygens he said ether is constituted of
particles newton ether is made up of
numerous small particles and john
johann bernoulli uh ether is comprised
of excessively small whirlpools all
these people thought of the ether as a
bunch of particles that's what the
that's the notion they had of the ether
okay and again some of them said it
fills space most of them have that
notion others equate it with space and
say
space and wither are the same thing it's
like the backdrop to every little thing
that we have here on on earth or in the
universe but the problem there is that
space is considered to be infinite
meaning the ether is infinite and
there's a difference between you know an
object a thing like an ocean right
and uh something which is infinite which
is not a something at all
if it's infinite it's the opposite of an
object object is that which is finite
okay and infinite means that it's not an
object still growing or you haven't
conceptualized it properly you can't see
the edges of it the surface whatever
it's not an object so if you're going to
treat the ether as an object i want you
to draw it okay you got to put a picture
of that you also have to explain what
encapsulates it yeah yeah and we'll get
to that in a second here in fact uh here
is okay
uh see all these objects are finite okay
and um
here you have the solid okay
uh you have a liquid and you have a gas
and they're all fine all those are
objects those are things in fact if
they're made of atoms they had better be
things because an
atom is a thing so anything made of
atoms had also better be a thing okay
and so solids liquids and gases are all
things okay
okay but uh here we have what an object
is in fact uh
what you just said here okay here's an
object okay we'll call that air just a
blob of air and we've frozen the picture
we took a snapshot of air and
unfortunately it was
colorful so we could
see what it looks like that's what that
blob is in one frame of the movie okay
now as you can see i haven't uh i've got
some black stuff around it but that
black stuff i put a uh a frame around it
but that frame is artificial
uh the black stuff is not infinite it's
not finite because it's not an object
it's a concept it's black stuff is
nothing that's what it's known as and
nothing is that which doesn't have shape
but if you want to argue that space is
ether ether is space and that space is a
physical object or that ether is a
physical object okay
then you got to do the following which
is what he just mentioned and that's
that you got to tell me what the white
stuff is that encapsulates the ether
assuming it has shape or shape yeah yeah
it's got it the
is finite yeah
yeah and that means there's something
that's around it right something has to
give it contrast so you got to identify
the white stuff okay
so that's that's your task if you cannot
i draw if you cannot make a picture of
the ether
or you and you cannot draw something
around it and tell me what that white
stuff is you do you cannot even start
your presentation we're not done with
your proposal
is usually where all the time
you gotta you gotta spend two thousand
years on the assumptions in five seconds
for your dumb theory we don't care about
that
right
okay so here we have the other b those
were the ethers then you have the
electric universers okay here these
people say electric electricity is
flowing potential for work
flowing potential you have we have a
concept that is flowing
now that is scary okay and again uh you
know uh electricity is a river
it's electrons that are flowing so you
can't say electricity flows or current
flows that's irrational electrons okay
and then he says plasma the first state
of matter i don't know i thought the
first state what was it uh south
carolina or virginia well that was the
first date i can't remember now
yeah there is no such thing as a first
state of matter okay and if uh plasma is
a state of any kind which means what
something does then for sure plasma is
not a thing because a verb is not a noun
okay so i hope you understood that
okay it says what the web telescope
reveals must even amaze and all bill's
physics cynicism
yeah um we don't care what the web uh
telescope james webb telescope uh
reveals because uh we don't we don't
care about evidence
we try to make sense of how this
universe works and for that we don't
need evidence at all evidence is what
you use to convince not to
uh explain
we here explain and we try to explain in
a rational manner
rational means that we're not going to
move concepts around such as what was it
potential the flow of potential whoa the
potential is flowing that's dangerous
the flow of potential jumping and here
you have another uh movement of concepts
this is mr wahl thornhill and he's uh
the head honcho at the electric universe
and all these statements here come from
his um a video he made recently twisted
pairs and braids everywhere okay but the
problem is the twisted pears and braids
these filaments
are not things he calls them filaments
but they're they are electricity they're
flowing flows that's what they are the
flowy the flow of flows
okay and there you see filaments are
like those in a plasma ball you've seen
all those little things that come out of
a plasma ball you know those lights
you're saying those are the filaments
okay so what are they they're currents
rotating birkeland currents gravity
alone cannot produce each twisting and
turning filament structures okay so the
issue is he's he's calling them
filaments but what is a filament is the
flow of electricity okay the flow of
flows again flow of electrons that are
flowing
okay that's what he's saying so he draws
them he draws them as two
as a pair of twine uh threads you know a
rope
but that's very very misleading because
he's not talking about threads he's not
talking about wires he's not talking
about uh you know strings or anything
like that wires you know any of any of
those what he's talking about each one
of those strands that you see there
that's electricity flowing meaning
electrons which are flowing
okay and he has these electron flows
twine around each other
okay so he doesn't even know what he's
doing he doesn't know what he's saying
so he said rotating electric currents
that flow
what do you mean a current flows and it
flows as a filament helically twisted
pairs and braids no these are not braids
please do not confuse a braid with a
flow of electrons okay if that's what he
means by you know electricity is it
because he's talking about the
trajectory yeah he's talking about the
trajectory of a bunch of electrons you
know that he's having combining their
trajectories yeah yeah and he calls him
braids but that's the thing he's he's
again nounifying the verb exactly he's
turning verbs into nouns it's like you
talk about the the how was it super
mouse or what was that that one show
called where the lamb would stand on oh
yeah it's a
mighty mouse and mighty mouse has this
uh this uh contrail
behind and the and the uh she the lamb
walks along the contrail he essentially
turned the contrails into something
a little more solid you know and that's
what this fellow is doing you know and
he says filaments are electric currents
no if filaments are electric currents
then he's talking about nonsense they're
not braids he should not call them
filaments or braids which refer to
physical objects whereas his so-called
filament these currents they are not
physical object current is is a river
okay and unless you understand the
language
you know you're talking nonsense and and
that's what all these people do and when
you point that out to them and say well
you're doing semantics bill i didn't
come here to learn grammar i came here
to do physics
well to put it nicely you know physics
is 150
semantics
okay if you do not do semantics we're
not going to understand what you're
saying especially if you say that your
filament is uh curving around and
turning into a braid when you're talking
about the flow of electrons
okay and again if you're going to have a
flow of electrons like the electric
universe says you better have atoms that
you know the electrons move from one
atom to another what these people think
is that they can do without the atom all
together and you have only the electron
beads moving across the universe from
one galaxy to another no such monster in
science or in physics
current is not the flow of just
electrons without any atoms underneath
it okay current you know is according to
the official version because this is not
even current but
conceding it you know that the official
version is correct current is an
electron that moves from one atom to the
next there's no such monster as no atoms
and the electrons just a bunch of
electrons flowing across the universe
that is total nonsense that's what the
electric universe believes in that's
what they're proposing that electrons
alone form these filaments and these
filaments which are just you know water
flowing you know
and then they twist around they form
these twisted filaments called braids or
whatever that's total bunk it's nonsense
all of it trash completely in the trash
can but to be honest when you have that
much i think
yeah
that much
you're gonna always have semantical
issues because words just kind of
complicate things yeah but you got to
just draw how much right from yeah what
i'm saying is i don't it's hard to evade
that because in the end this is better
just to watch the movie of how the
universe works yeah also but
hold it but see if he watches if we
watch his movie right of the two braids
yeah right you would think that you're
looking at something and they're not
talking about something but there is or
something which is the electron tiny
electron but they pull a million of
these or gazillions of them they turn
them into a tube
and they say well yeah it's a filament
then we have these twisted filament they
turned into a braid and and you lost
track of what they're talking about they
hit you with the trajectory of the
freaking election
they throw the baseball bat and then
they take the trajectory where it
travels and they hit you with that stick
okay so uh just in case yeah here we
have a fellow he says no one in the
electric universe community has ever
claimed that gravity is equivalent to
electricity because i mentioned that the
other day what they say is that gravity
is an electric phenomenon aha okay
if i say my car is electric that doesn't
mean i'm saying my car is equivalent to
electricity
okay you see his argument one is an
adjective and the other is a noun learn
the difference okay let's see if i need
to learn the difference or maybe he
needs to uh learn something here okay
let's find out i think it is learning
okay car is an irrational analogy for
the comparison of electricity and
gravity both are processes phenomena
car is electric is not equal to gravity
is electricity
okay
so yeah car is a noun and electric is an
adjective but here he's comparing apples
and oranges when he uses that
analogy right here we're talking about
gravity and electricity both of which
are verbs they're not nouns for the
purposes of physics both gravity and
electricity are processes phenomena
meaning verbs okay
so let's get it right okay and uh yeah
apparently needs to learn some language
again the language of physics
and uh here let's uh
show them this is what uh
two sources which i pointed out last
time one comes from the electric
universe book this is their handbook a
beginner's view of our electric universe
by tom findlay
and here's the following again gravity
is a manifestation of the
electromagnetic force gravity itself is
fundamentally what electrical and just
another what aspect of the
electromagnetic force
the four fundamental forces the weak
strong forces electromagnetism
and wet gravity will all eventually be
seen as having your common root in the
electromagnetic force according to the
electric universe there is no such thing
as gravity at all
anywhere in the universe it's all
electric
all electricity and there we have at the
bottom mr walt thornhill the head honcho
i mean if he doesn't know i don't know
who does
says the force of gravity is a
manifestation of the electric force okay
and gravity is an electric dipole force
between subatomic particles there is no
such thing as gravity according to the
electric universe i mean that's fine if
they can say that no no
but this guy's denying it this guy said
bill you're wrong because
we didn't say that gravity is
electricity yes that's what they say
exactly you don't know your own religion
you go every sunday to sunday school
electric sunday school
and and you listen to the pastor talking
instead of the plus for the cross they
have a nightmare and he doesn't even
understand his own religion yeah
according to the electric universe there
is no such thing as gravity gravity is
is the wrong word it's an inexistent
word should be taken out of the
dictionary everything is electricity
and that contradicts what they say which
is that gravity is
orders of magnitude
uh weaker than electricity
so they have a contradiction on the one
hand they say electricity is not gravity
because gravity is much weaker
than electricity and then on the other
say look ultimately everything's
electricity and there's no such thing as
gravity so they have these
contradictions that's why the electric
universe is absolute nonsense poppycock
okay and i say it here okay uh again uh
for those who don't understand
i think the roller's gonna break before
too many yeah yeah
okay
okay so here we have the all these flat
landers as i call them okay and because
of that they have no idea what gravity
is because they never use gravity they
use the acceleration of earth going up i
thought well because the problem here is
that they use concepts to define or to
explain gravity so when you use concept
other concepts such as ether and
electricity to explain gravity all
you're saying is that love is a
different way of doing uh intelligence
and so far you said nothing you said uh
or like einstein said uh mass is another
form of energy well so far he said
nothing because neither energy nor mass
belong to physics and both are concepts
none of them have been defined
with each other so it becomes yeah
tautology and uh circular reasoning so
here you have it okay so these are the
the great uh
bean brains of uh flat land okay one
flatlander says gravity is warp time
another one says gravity is energy
another one says it's density another
one electricity another one says it's
negative momentum transfer
this is what they came up with all this
nonsense why because they're using
concepts
they're using constant time energy
electricity all those are concepts you
cannot say the concept gravity is the
concept of electricity or the concept
momentum or whatever yeah where where
are the objects yeah we need to find the
objects and we don't see any objects
here so far nothing's doing anything
yeah all you have is one concept of
defining another concept or you're
explaining supposedly explaining
quotations on that explaining gravity by
using another concept and we haven't
learned anything as long as you say that
love is just another form of
intelligence or data collection you
haven't said anything well maybe
again a lot a lot of these semantical
problems arise from our preconceived
notions of all these words if you just
replace those words with x
yeah yeah and then it gets then you want
at least i mean you'll be confused but
for a different reason but then if you
defined x you'd get closer than saying
time this time we all have different
ideas of what time is and and it's hard
to define and they never define it i
know but you get into this whole mess
you just said x
moves
people and that's why gravity that's
what gravity is is is mediated by x then
you still have to explain what x is and
you have to draw that's one issue the
other important issue is that you
learned all these
concepts mathematical concepts in high
school and you think you know what they
mean yeah and in fact a lot of people
drop out of uh physically and say i
didn't understand anything other than
all those uh force and work and energy i
didn't understand anything so they say
i'm out of here and those people who say
okay i think i understand it and all
they give you is an equation look force
is equal mass times acceleration uh work
is equal to that energy is equal to that
and so all they're giving you is a bunch
of equations calling them names and then
using those words which are concepts to
explain a to give you a physical
interpretation that's where the problem
that's when they cross the line into
physics that's where it's illegal that's
where it's you're right
red card
stop
you get a ticket okay so uh they don't
know nope none of these people know what
gravity is and here you have uh what we
were doing these other uh days okay
uh we start out with this situation
where we have this is your new obsession
well yeah i'm just gonna because
nobody's answered that but essentially
we have a tree
okay and we built the van over the tree
okay
and uh what happens uh you have to do an
experiment we have a car on a chair yeah
so so we we put up we built the car on a
tree or let's say you say we parked the
car there for a long time and a tree
grew under it just to be clear there's
no floor on the car yeah there's no
floor and the the tree is not touching
any part of the van it's just underneath
it okay not touching any part of the
band it's exactly in that sense like
that molecule that atom there whatever
you want to call it a particle okay
but what happened the air molecule okay
it's just floating around okay so what
happens when we accelerate the van okay
this is what you should expect okay the
tree stays behind but it turns out that
the particle also stays behind okay so
we ask you why did the tree stay behind
and you say well the tree is stuck to
the ground well why did the particle
stay behind if it's not stuck to the
ground okay you see where the problem is
you have to answer why the particles
stay behind
and what do people answer they say well
a force did not a force you know force
being a physical object
force did not push the particle
that's what they say
it never occurred to them that maybe a
force whatever that force is
kept it there
so they only talk about moving it but
see they didn't say that for the tree
they said well the tree didn't move not
because the force didn't push it until
the van touched it right the back of the
van but because it's stuck to the ground
okay that's how they say okay so we have
to create a different situation for
these people to understand now we have
the tree just lying underneath here it's
not stuck to the ground okay
so neither the tree nor the particle are
stuck to the ground what happens when
the van accelerates well now both of
them again stay behind
in the case of the tree now you say what
again the force did not come and push
the tree is that what you're going to
say
how about uh a force
keeping it there before something pushed
it did you ever have any yeah
exactly we're talking about gravity and
gravity good old gravity and that's
right electricity and so here we have
the situation where some people say well
you know we have all these molecules
that are keeping the particle in place
and so but if that were the case you
know other air molecules then the band
would move all mark particles at the
same time including the one that the
target molecule right the target atom or
whatever target particle okay so you
can't say that the reason that particle
stayed behind is because it was kept in
place by all these other molecules
because if that were the case they would
all move together
instead what we see is this situation
okay where um
give it a second here
where some particles are being pushed
first
uh
sorry
did i get the right one
oh
i guess that's the one i meant
i got the wrong one there it is
oh okay
that's what i want to see okay so here
you see see the particles are being
pushed one at a time you can see the red
particle does not move until the other
particles touch it
you know and so the issue is
what keeps the red particle in place and
you might say the other particles see
but the other particles are touching all
the other particles so you can't say
that it's the other particles that keep
it in place something else is keeping
that red particle in place aside from
all the molecules that are uh you know
next to it that's what you've
got of gravity pulling it against the
sea of marbles correct correct so we do
have a sea of marbles underneath it but
that's not the only force
right acting upon it we have the force
of gravity let's not use the word force
yeah and so we have to identify what the
force of gravity is okay and so here we
have it okay and this is just a picture
of that we need to know why the molecule
the red molecule there
is staying in place until the other
molecules that are pushed by the band
come in contact with it that means that
the other molecules are not the only
ones keeping it in place because here i
artificially drew some spaces between
them when there are no spaces okay so
that's the situation
okay
so what do we propose well we say
gravity is something else and it looks
more or less like this the particle
stays in place aside because of all the
other molecules because every atom on
earth is bound to that molecule and that
molecules bound to every atom on earth
okay i didn't draw the
connections okay
but that molecule is staying in place be
more or less in place it does move a
little bit right in their region but not
as fast as when the van hits it right
but you can see it's staying more or
less in place why because it's connected
to every atom on earth and here we have
someone who vouches for that and there's
mr richard muller did you did you you
missed any money
so thank you every atom on earth is
pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
okay and now the question is how do you
explain that statement there those two
statements there
how do you explain those two statements
with ether with electricity with
space-time i'll let you have your pick i
don't care okay you pick whatever you
want please explain how every atom on
earth is pulling on every atom of you
and how you're pulling also pulling on
it with anything that comes to your mind
i don't care okay just explain it
explain those two statements if you
cannot explain those two statements you
have no theory that's worth even
listening to
okay so that's the situation
people say oh i know everything about
gravity it's the ether it's the
electricity just tell me how or space
time or whatever just tell me how it is
that every atom on earth is pulling on
that atom on every atom in your body and
how every atom of your body is pulling
on every atom on earth gravity goes
right through things that's what mr
mulder said does that mean the gravity
particles that every atom is shooting to
every atom
would that be the thing well if you're
shooting yeah every atom on earth would
have to be shooting these negative the
negative momentum oh negative momentum
wow
to every other atom that means at every
moment it's shooting just a line of
things through the other through the
others too
yeah
if you're gonna do this with gravitons
well good luck you got a big mess guy
would go crazy with his computer trying
to throw all these little balls through
other balls to hit this and bring it
back i mean through the other ball oh my
god
yeah
okay so um one fellow says yeah we do it
with our rope model okay the rope those
are the connections that we propose one
fellow says
says your ropes are a concept
ropes are a concept
my god some people it looks like i don't
think this fellow went through
kindergarten did he ever play with
blocks well i would i would say the
reason why someone would say something
like this is because we can't see it so
we have to conceptualize its shape but
that doesn't make it a concept that just
makes it really small we're getting
there we're getting there uh is a tree a
concept is a rock a concept
this person is an atom a concept
yeah again it's really small we can't
see it but we can all conceptualize yeah
they go nuts they go crazy they go wacko
when they can't see or touch something
that they say oh that's a concept
it has nothing to do with sea touch
intangibility uh invisibility none of
that has nothing to do with that but
that's been
3 000 years of history in so-called
science mathematical physics that's what
people thought an object is that which
you can see your touch so if they can't
see or touch it they say it's not a
thing it's not an object it's a concept
not true
likewise they say for all these
geometric figures you know like uh
squares they say that's that's a concept
you're staring at an object it's got
shape and you're saying it's a concept
again the notion of concept that they
have in ordinary speech in irrational
language yeah
anything you can imagine who knows what
a concept is over there right
in physics
a a concept has a spec it has to be
defined it's got to be defined because
you got to separate it from objects okay
and that's where we're headed to okay so
here it is
uh here's uh one fella who
made a difference between all these you
know and separated them so the ones on
your left are objects the ones on your
right are concepts
okay and those are mathematical concepts
specifically okay most of them i think
all of them um and you can't use
concepts as objects not in physics and
what do we say say there are only two
categories of words in the dictionary
every word in the dictionary can be
placed under either object or concept i
guess there's also filler words like of
and and yeah those are concepts as well
right and we're gonna get to that as
well yeah we're gonna look at some of
those okay i thought those are like just
like no no prepositions pronouns all
those are concepts
okay
object has to have shape
concept that which doesn't that's not
the definition that's a rule of thumb to
detect the word real quickly like does
it have shape does energy have shape
does mass have shape this time have
shape if it doesn't immediately you put
in the concept bin
okay that's the way it works if it has
shape you know a table a rock
a rope which this guy says is a concept
he thinks that a rope is a concept no
rope is an object always here and in the
land of the klingons okay always an
object
okay and uh so here
ah see if i can get it in here here you
have a
couple notions here you have these um uh
the object the one on the ones in red
and then what they do is known as a
concept okay so you cannot confuse this
air is the object it's the thing okay
and air does have shape for those of you
who say well what is the shape of air no
that's not the question the question is
does air have shape and yeah air does
have shape you take you put it in a
balloon it's got balloon shape
you put it around the earth it's got
shell shape and so on uh for those of
you who believe in the spherical earth
well one of the questions actually about
this okay they drew a tornado and said
that that's that it's a process which
has shape but this is exactly what
you're talking about yeah a tornado is
moving air so it's uh not a thing wind
there you have it hurricane
tornado those are not physical objects
those are things in motion okay uh like
plasma plasma is a thing in motion it's
weird that we yes like flame and tornado
aren't actual objects yeah really
i mean but if you put it that way aren't
we also
processes
because we're
who like human beings like if you take a
human being no because because they are
not the collection of their atoms you
know let's get real real deep
philosophical
you replace
all your atoms all your molecules every
seven years they say approximately
because because your your body
replenishes itself
you're getting ahead of yourself someone
also got it yeah
no no let me show you the difference
i take a snapshot of you you're running
right you're jogging and i take a
snapshot of you
that's an object because i can put you
in a single uh you know
this is you right yeah
a man
we'll call it a man okay well that's
what you can call it x if you want we'll
call it a man okay jimmy yeah okay no
because jimmy is different than johnny
but that's a concept jimmy is a guy but
man meaning man could be a woman you
know my point is human you can say
that's a that's an object
i take a picture of a tornado i get air
i don't get tornado
okay tornado is in mode i need to see a
movie but you can take a picture of a
flame i can take a picture of flame i i
don't have plane
well you could say that's what i'm
saying
you're in the same bucket because you
could what i'm saying is it depends on
what level of analysis you're doing it
because you could either be
because i'm i essentially depends on
what you mean by flame okay flame is a
tricky word and i did have analyzed it
in fact i treat flame as an object only
because again i can take a picture of
nmc and i can point to the klingon and
say flame so as far as the klingon is
concerned all he sees is something
yellow reddish there and bright red and
he says aflame okay that's frame
flame okay but if you're gonna say that
flame is part of the process of
combustion then flame is not an object
so it depends on what you mean when you
point and say flame which one are you
referring to fire is always a process of
combustion therefore fire is not an
object it gets when it gets so it's
definitely worth worth mentioning yeah
and we're talking about what exactly are
you talking about are you talking about
the table or the atoms that make the
table right and you talk about the
tornado are you talking about the
the air that makes the tornado and again
all these things uh what we're trying to
do is teach the language of physics but
it gets shaky with tornado because it
implies motion right right and hurricane
hurricane motion uh tsunami motion it's
air in motion the object is air
okay that is interesting and air is a
physical object because it does have
shape you can point i can make a shape
with air with all these atoms and call
it air and that is a physical a good uh
contrast would be the word plate
because you got a plate it's made of
porcelain it's made of atoms for you
know molecules and porcelain
so you could be talking about it you
could take a snapshot of it you don't
even need the snapshot part right it's
really just there's no verb that that's
implied in the word played but there is
a verb
implied to certain so so i guess it gets
tricky yeah but see the the word tornado
already implies a verb the word plasma
involves a verb but but essentially the
ionization you could break these down
into three categories almost there's
these there's objects that are static no
matter how you talk about there's no
verbs
those are the only objects
just to steer me out first and there's
those like halfway ones which are these
like tornado fire where
they're part atoms but we also give it
it they imply verbs yeah and then
there's the mathematical nouns which are
just verbs like force
yeah um so it's like we got flame is
like a halfway point yeah
like you know some people say well it's
a cloud yeah an object yeah a cloud is
an object because i can take a snapshot
and whatever atoms are there for me in
that cloud that's the object at that
point in time if i can put it one frame
and there's no motion involved the word
cloud does not involve any motion
whatsoever okay yeah it moves from frame
to frame but within a frame there's no
motion and i still have a cloud punch
punch is a good good noun
it's not a noun
yeah but that's what i mean but it's
it's a noun because you could take a
snapshot of someone getting punched and
someone say oh a punch yeah but you know
no no no no no because if the if the um
all he says oh he's he's uh scraping his
he's he's massaging his side
you know i mean you don't know punch is
something else it's motion but his fist
fist in motion it's like flame atoms in
motion okay so let's look at the
definition of concept here it is
concept a word that invokes or embodies
two objects
uh synonyms relation comparison contrast
you have to have something like that
okay
so it requires a human
object is to one what concept is to to
mother nature provided all objects
humans invented all concepts
okay do we have that
that's uh
that's where uh the
word concept gets defined
now let's look at some examples so that
and these are not the million examples
that are in the dictionary just a few so
that you can get the idea the hang of it
okay here it is okay informal definition
concept that which has no shape you can
use that to as a rule of thumb to
determine what
words in the dictionary fall under
objects which went under concepts here
we have static constant concepts versus
dynamic concepts okay
static concepts distance direction
perpendicular parallel none of these
words on the left
uh involve um
motion they have no verb in in
embedded in them all the ones on the
right on the other hand have motion
okay meter okay and i'll let you figure
that one why that one has motion in it
forward okay breath
uh i mean you know length
i'm sorry death breath elevation you
know those are all involve motion tandem
one thing after another series perimeter
perimeter is something you go around
okay
uh love
it's a dynamic concept
[Music]
infinity means you're still walking
towards nowhere right
people plural nouns you know butter all
those uh kind of like uh that you know
people because the collection yeah it's
a collection like forest not not butter
but foreign
yeah yeah and that's why i put some of
these up there so that people can go in
there and look at you know the word
motion in ordinary speech it's a noun
not in physics in physics it's a verb
okay
living uh not the same thing as exists
some people say uh one of the synonyms
is living absolutely not exists there is
no motion living there is
okay so again a lot of these uh
we're again trying to teach you how to
talk i don't know i don't think people
is a concept though
even under your definition
yeah people is like a plate
no no no it's a collection of atoms yeah
but yeah but people refers to different
tb when you look at plate you're not
saying it's a collection of atoms no but
in the case of people there's a
collection of people of humans when you
look at forests you're looking at
collection of trees so it's a collection
any collection
you know stamp collection what's the
intuitive force in the plate
that plate you're not referring to its
constituents whereas uh it's irrelevant
is what you're saying no what i'm saying
is when you talk about people when you
talk about forest words such as those
which are children you know and so on um
what you're referring to is what is
known as mereology what something is
constituted by okay in the case of
people you're not referring to
a shape called people you're referring
to what uh constitutes the word people
which is many human in other words
people means many humans foreign
okay one fellow criticizes this he says
self-made definitions he doesn't like
him it's ludicrous to believe there are
only concepts and objects
he doesn't say why he just says he gave
his opinion okay we clean our noses
with your opinion unless you give it a
reason we have no idea when space motion
collision energies are neither
well uh so
why are they none and he says concept an
abstract idea well it looks like motion
collision energies are abstract ideas so
why wouldn't those be
uh part of concepts according to his own
proposal which is an abstract idea
okay and again you know
these famous theorists with big ideas
but what is the problem here it is okay
idea you look it up it says any
conception i thought conception was what
we wanted to define well you look up
conception it says a notion
idea concept so their synonym what is a
notion conception or idea what's an idea
a thought a conception or motion
or a notion what is a thought thinking
idea or notion all those from the
dictionary what is abstract because it
says an abstract idea right abstract
thought of
part from concrete reality specific
objects or actual instances
okay and so uh i put that all in one
nice little little neat
little um uh
chart and here you see it so you can see
idea is the same thing as a conception
which is the same thing as a thought
which is the same thing as a notion
all these are synonyms so this poor
fellow he hasn't said absolutely
anything okay he just copied and pasted
what he found out there without
analyzing any of it so he's got a
synonym okay and so we have to you know
get away from synonyms we can't use
synonyms to define words
yeah get rid of the thesaurus yeah
okay and then regarding his other
statement uh you know uh that he said
these are my personal definitions
irrelevant all definitions are personal
someone came up with them do you know
who the thousands of definitions in the
dictionary came from
who came up with them jimmy yeah i guess
thanks for your god half of them maybe
god came up with them no they say like
shakespeare made like 10 of them
i do just they don't work so all
definitions are self-made someone made
them okay
and you can't use you know um you know
copy paste definition just say look
we've used this uh by tradition we've
always used these definitions uh
everybody voted for these definitions or
say well this is how i was taught in
college by authority i had a very strong
teacher who
muscled me into believing them you know
none of that is is an argument you
either have a rational definition which
we can put into science or you have no
definition at all you have a definition
of ordinary speech which it normally is
not of any use in science so if the
definition is wrong if it's broken you
got to fix it okay that's essentially it
so you can't say i've always used it
like that well i don't care well you
know you've been saying one of them and
the other one if you if you cannot
explain you cannot defend your
definition your definition is worth plus
well it's like i keep telling you
everyone just is satisfied with notions
just approximation of definition yeah
but that's not good enough because you
get what i'm talking about you get
someone like me who is a bully who
beats up little kids and so on and he
comes in and he's going to beat you up
with his
what you mean exactly is
you're gonna find the kinks in the
notion like well what do you mean by
this though
and not in a and not in a devil's
advocating just to tear you down way but
just to
it's like ironing out the words like
like putting him into stone what's the
most the cleanest least confusing way of
phrasing these that's one
the other thing is that you know uh
first of all definitions scientific
definitions should be as short as
possible to leave very little for the
devil's advocate to chop okay because if
you have definitions like the word
science or the scientific method or some
of these other words you see out there
they have long paragraphs those are easy
to tear down because you can tear down
any piece of that it's not only that it
really comes down it's kind of again
back to programming where you if if a
definition is too long you probably need
two words
you gotta you gotta break it into
smaller words
yeah if you've got a definition that
that has too many
um events or no just too many too many
uh what's the word
conditions
to be met yeah then the word is just to
and that's what i'm saying
because then it's easier also to chop
for the double that it's just too
convoluted like it's too hard of a word
to use correctly and the computer would
not understand unless you used it
perfectly but even then it's better to
use smaller words
okay
you gotta use small
words not not just so people don't get
confused really that's one issue but the
other one is you don't want to introduce
words of ordinary speech which you use
or what you learn by road copy paste it
and bring them into science without any
you know indiscriminately but you got to
go in there and analyze say does this
make sense if it doesn't make sense
don't say well i found it legitimately
that i mean and this is what i yeah you
can't say this way i got to you really
the other thing you gotta you gotta
understand is
a lot of the words used by mathematical
physicists you know mathematicians
have been
written by
people who have no stake in the matter
and by gram grammarians uh
english majors librarians you know
people who have no stake in physics they
define the word for the physics and the
verses says oh i found it in the
dictionary
no idea what he's even done so so we're
using this word for so so again you have
to ask that person was that your
personal definition
uh uh did you did you self-create this
definition they also act like the
definition for these things like if you
if you look at this stone yeah it's like
it's gonna like this guy invented it and
that's what it means forever yeah no it
doesn't work in fact we redefine words
every day when we find problems with it
and that's what we're doing here
we're teaching you how to uh speak if
you're gonna do physical interpretation
i bet you you should you should you
would probably have a ball having being
on a podcast with like a linguist or
something people who really delve into
the the the purpose of words i think you
would have a blast talking to that
person
okay let's finish up here the golden
principle of physics okay physics is
done with objects you can't do physics
with concepts you cannot move concepts
around the irrational concept that
mathematicians treat as objects and move
around are those on your bottom right
you can choose any one of those and
those are all irrational terms because
they are concepts which are treated as
objects
that's where the problem is
okay
comments questions
there's a lot of comments and questions
but i think we're gonna have to do it
differently i think we have to reserve a
day where people just ask questions and
we just talk to them directly because
your presentation is too long well we'll
try and cover some some of this is
remember it's uh
recap
but i'm just saying like to answer
people's comments sometimes it it really
just it should be the whole day
okay here's uh our science critic okay
we'll get to him okay and here it is uh
he said that uh essentially he said that
magnetism
has been explained by our great uh white
fathers let's find out if that's true
give me a second here okay here it goes
listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
does the mathematical establishment have
any idea whatsoever what physical
mechanism underlies magnetic attraction
or repulsion
and
do the mathematicians have an
explanation of the causes that underlie
magnetism
or merely a description
well that comes down to magnetic domains
when magnetic domains are aligned they
produce a magnetic field and when you
produce a magnetic field that can exert
a force on other materials yes magnetism
is a difficult thing to understand it
can seem like magic
but there are rational explanations for
it
do the mathematicians have rational
explanations for he didn't
explain it no he didn't explain he just
said oh there are explanations out there
okay let's find out let's find out and
i'm not i'm gonna just bring testimony
here okay i'll let the physicists at the
mathematical physicists tell you in
their own words okay here's the first
one this is mr richard feynman some of
you know him he was a nobel prize with
1965
and this is what mr feinman had to say
about how much he knows about magnetism
and i think some of you
heard this but somewhere but here it is
again one more time here it goes listen
carefully
if you get hold of two magnets and you
push them you can feel this pushing
between them turn around the other way
and then they slam together why are they
doing that or how are they doing it
uh you're asking i i must say i think
that's a perfectly reasonable question
of course it's a reason it's an
excellent question
okay
but the problem that you're asking you
see when you ask why something happens
how does a person answer why something
happens
now when you ask for example
why two magnets repel
there are many different levels it
depends on whether you're a student of
physics or an ordinary person that
doesn't know anything you're not if
you're somebody who doesn't know
anything at all about it all i can say
is that there's a magnetic force that
makes them repel and that you're feeling
that thought
i'm am i answering your question but i'm
telling you how difficult a why question
is you have to know
what it is
that you're permitted to understand and
allow to be understood and known and
what it is you're not well i've just
have to tell you that's going to be one
of the things you'll just have to
take as an element in the world the
existence of magnetic repulsion or
electrical
electrical attraction magnetic
attraction
i can't explain that attraction in terms
of anything else that's familiar to you
so i'm not going to be able to give you
an answer to why magnets attract each
other except to tell you that they do
but i really can't do a good job
any job
of explaining magnetic force in terms of
something else that you're more familiar
with because i don't understand it in
terms of anything else that you're more
familiar with
okay so that was a great explanation by
mr richard feynman how a magnet
attraction repels another great
explanation didn't you think so and so i
don't know what this fall is talking
about because richard feynman didn't
know that in 1965 here is uh another
fellow and he's from ucla this is today
okay and this is the explanation
quotation on that of how a magnet
attracts another okay
uh listen carefully here give me a
second
magnets
one magnet either repels
or attracts
another and nobody knows why
except you
after watching today's video
naturally occurring minerals were found
to attract iron in the ancient greek
region of magnesia
and so were actually named for the area
and these rocks were found to either
attract
or repel
one another
one way to understand magnets is through
magnetic domains you see unmagnetized
iron metal is composed of a whole bunch
of tiny little crystal magnets called
domains and they're randomly oriented
pointing in all different directions but
magnetized iron has all the domains
aligned that is it has a north side and
a south side and that orientation is
what allows it to become a magnet
during the magnetization process the
domains flip suddenly
this flipping can be made audible
i have here a small piece of nickel
which i'm placing inside of this coil of
wire
any rapid changes in magnetic field will
sound on this speaker here
i also have a very strong
magnets which i placed on the north end
of this little magnet
when i bring it close to the nickel
listen
do you hear the domains flipping
and there you have it
a new magnet
this iron paper clip can be magnetized
by this magnet
the magnetic domains in the paperclip
can be destroyed by heating
[Applause]
and the magnetism is lost
besides iron
cobalt and nickel are also magnetic
their proximity on the periodic table
lets you know that magnetism is a result
of electron valence that is
all magnetism is caused by electrons
this coil of wire with a looping current
is acting just like a bar magnet
causing compasses to point out of north
and into south
out of north and into south
could it be that the electrons orbiting
the iron atoms are the net cause of
magnetism
that is could it be that circling
electrons are causing the magnetic field
in 1915 albert einstein and van der
dehaas ran an experiment to check that
it was the orbiting electrons that
caused magnetism
the results were negative
later on it was discovered that
electrons had a property called spin
that is the electron was spinning
as it circled the nucleus
it's the alignment these electrons spins
that results in the magnetic properties
of iron
okay
so
what did he say he says the only reason
that a magnet attracts another is
because the electrons spin
okay so the electron spin how does that
make one magnet attract another you
never explain he just says
the
domains are aligned in each magnet okay
he said the electron spin in each magnet
okay how does that produce attraction
so he never explained how a magnet
attracts another just like mr richard
feynman said
so this uh
science critic he doesn't understand
that he's he thinks he's got an
explanation or that there must be an
explanation out there no they don't have
explanations not a single
uh invisible intangible process
right out there or phenomenon out there
can be explained by any mathematician on
earth and has never been explained in
the last 3000 years the only way you're
going to explain it if you introduce the
invisible intangible objects that
mediate those transactions
period
and if you do not think that there's
there are invisible intangible objects
out there that serve as mediators
between objects meaning you're gonna do
action at a distance all you're doing is
black magic
you're saying this one moves here and it
moves the other one over there without
anything in between them simply what
because you can't see or touch it
and that's the situation right now
that's why these people uh cannot
explain it and that's the only parent
yeah
no because they're not into that
business they're in the business of
doing equations they have that science
well rather than the business of
dangling keys in front of you with
authority making you think that they
explained it and saying oh man they must
it sounds like they understand it
because i'm too dumb to
okay so one fellow says this the thing
that connects every atom to every other
atom is invisible intangible
i remember when you used to say uh you
can own uh you can only uh do physics
with physical objects
yeah see this fellow believes that an
object's that which is visible
intangible
and again if you've got that irrational
notion of the of what an object is if
you have that irrational definition of
course you're never going to discover
gravity well it's rational until tested
yeah until you put it to the test yeah
yeah right but uh that's what i mean it
makes sense you're going to be testing
the definition you're saying look that
definition is irrational you can't use
that in physics i wouldn't say it's
irrational i think it's it's it's just
not good enough because it's
understandable you can understand what
he's saying yeah but in that sense you
know why it's it's irrational because of
the following it's it's irrational
because
people say okay uh i'm gonna go to the
lab and run a test
what tests are you going to run what
tests are you going to run first of all
because you're trying to test or try and
run an experiment on something that's
invisible and intangible that's the
first issue but then you have another
issue and that is that you need a second
object to do the seeing and touching
that already makes it irrational i mean
it should be clear that you cannot use a
second object
to define
one object
okay and and so you have all these
you know and it's like i gotta run a
test if the asteroid does not hit a moon
the moon neither one is an object until
they touch until they you know they
touch each other and so and i can't see
that uh table on the other side of the
universe that the klingon has so because
i can't see it it's not an object so you
know from every point of view
this is an irrational definition we can
use it in ordinary speech but not in
science i still don't like the term
calling it an irrational definition
because it's a it's rational because you
can understand it but it's just not a
good definition i'm saying it's an
irrational definition because you need
two objects to define one that should be
clear
that you cannot use it in science you
know and so on anyways uh
so
this is what i answered this fall thing
is not that which is see touch thing is
that which has shape and those are
synonyms there and things see some
people confuse thing with exist no a
thing is not a synonym of existence
which is what david hume and uh emmanuel
kant
can't uh thought about i mean it should
be
yeah well in everyday life yeah i don't
know i mean like why should we even talk
about objects which don't exist
that's just something that's just a
human problem really yeah but we're not
talking only about objects that don't
exist we're talking about objects
that uh you know like a square which we
can imagine yeah it doesn't exist
because it doesn't have location if if
if you had people there that only knew
logic didn't know sarcasm or poetry
they would only do
physics with things that exist dogs cats
all they see is what they see and touch
you know yeah but then you have objects
which you could say exist like the rope
that interconnects two atoms we can't
see or touch it it doesn't have location
well under the
new notions that we have with the rope
model then
location is a different kind of word
that you really need to define because
we always define position location all
those
terms uh always uh using atoms you know
we always thought of something that has
location only that which is made of
atoms now we're saying look the rope is
not made of atoms does it have location
well you there is distance between two
ropes so in that sense you can say the
rope exists with relation to itself yeah
or
it gets weird you gotta you gotta
redefine these terms with the rope
unless you just straight up assume that
there's at least two threads in the
universe yeah and that's another issue
you know uh you can make that assumption
that there's two threads in the universe
or more and in that case all threads
exist all you know and
you can continue with that
anyways here's uh
another foul says in order to have shape
an object would need to retain shape for
more than one frame of a movie
and he says that you need uh to see the
sun in at least two frames in order for
it to have shape because it changes
shape from
one frame to another
you know it's absolute nonsense uh this
poor fellow he never went to
kindergarten
he should go back to playing with blocks
again yeah
you don't need two frames of the movie
for shape shape is a static concept it's
not a movie and you should see it in a
single frame so if i take a snapshot of
the sun and for that
snapshot
the sun has shaped and he said what is
the shape of it
wrong question the question is does
it have shape
okay i can get a whole bunch of atoms
that form air
and the question is does it have shape
not what is the shape of air that's an
irrational question for the for what
we're trying to answer here and the
question is does it have shape i got a
quick question here just for
clarification really someone asked isn't
the rope one rope the entire world
consists of
isn't the rope
one rope that the entire world consists
of
no when thread not one rope yeah okay
it's the thread
yeah yeah we should not confuse the
thread the single thread with the rope
rope is what lies between two atoms it's
always straight because it's talk
okay the thread on the other hand is
what makes up the atoms and the robes
and also forms the magnetic fields you
know a bunch of threads together that's
what we call the magnetic field a bunch
of threads moving
okay
not in general terms okay
and here another foul says i think it's
the same though you've never established
the existence of any such thing as a
physical object as a continuing
contiguous
block distinct from the rest of the
universe
he thinks that
there's a single block of matter
infinite lack of matter in the universe
and that there's no separation between
them
yeah the separation is known as space
that's what chops up
pieces of uh
objects you know one object from another
it's space that chops it up without
space
it would be a single block
uh of infinity
and that's not even an object because if
if you can't see the shape of it if you
cannot imagine the shape of it because
this thing is an infinite block then you
don't even have an object okay an object
that which has shape so yeah
and then he says an object is an
imaginary concept
you see what happens when people don't
define their terms we don't know what
this fellow thinks of as an object we
don't know what he thinks of as a
concept then he says 99.9 of the atom is
empty space
i think the space between your ears is
99 empty okay
uh only uh
only uh you know the mathematicians came
up with this notion that an atom is
mostly empty space we say something
different an atom is mostly
rows and threads okay which are
intangible and therefore it seems to the
mathematicians as if it were empty space
the empty space is between your ears
okay so never say that an atom is mostly
empty space
and uh
he says our senses can only perceive
motion
well i'm sorry to hear that from you you
know i can perceive objects uh here's an
object i can perceive it
and i don't have to see it move
okay i can see a picture of it i mean
he's not wrong
but he's talking about he's talking
about nonsense because he hasn't defined
any of his terms he doesn't know what
motion is can this uh being brain here
uh define motion
okay has he ever defined the word object
the word motion
okay he has it so talking to him is
talking to a wall okay because he
doesn't have any idea what these words
mean he's never defined them okay he
says an object is a concept i mean what
can he possibly understand
there's only two kinds of words objects
and concepts and hopefully they're not
synonyms that's true our senses can only
take emotion i guess then he says atoms
are not static bowling balls well thank
god yeah so what
uh i can take a picture of an atom and
at that moment in time you know i i can
see a picture of it and that is
an atom right now i don't have to see
the the word atom does not include any
motion in it there is no uh
motion involved in the word adam
okay
now do the electrons move yeah uh if if
you're going to use the
uh quantum model do protons move yeah
they spin and all that stuff we don't
care about all that you take can you
take a snapshot of an atom assuming
you're at a man and get one little ball
called the electron next to a proton
ball yeah that's what the atom is
according to quantum mechanics a proton
ball
next to an electron ball
and that is a static image you don't
need to have any of those to move in
order to say adam okay adam does not
include verbs does not include motion
and i guess this poor fellow does not
understand that he's never learned the
basics i don't think he even went to
kindergarten he never played with blocks
i think he did that's the problem
or he never graduated i guess no he did
that's the problem
and then he says here what do you say
the moment that an atom stops moving is
the moment it ceases to exist he never
defined the word exist so we don't know
what he means by exist so we define for
him an object with location location is
a static concept so is the word object
so exist is a static concept there is no
motion involved in the word exist if you
cease to exist the object has morphed
into space
meaning nothing it means at lost length
with and height
suddenly
spontaneously if you can explain that
process to me then we can just talk
about ceasing to exist okay again
because this poor fellow he doesn't
define his terms he goes around in
circles chasing his tail
okay
and another foul says
the electromagnetic ropes get tangled
because oh no i think the same file says
the electromagnetic roads don't get
tangled because they lack the property
of touch how convenient
no it's not that they it's convenient
it's that if you're gonna define these
terms and you're gonna have an
assumption on which to base your theory
it had better match to some degree at
least what mother nature has out there
and we can't see or touch what's
underneath the spoon when this spoon
falls right it falls to the ground and
we're saying that there's something here
that we cannot see or touch it's not
that it's convenient it's that i have to
define
the word in such a way that uh in other
words i have to identify the object that
is here which matches
mother nature's specification and
hopefully this is invisible
intentionally not so much
what it is yeah
this guy says no it's got to be
invisible and tangible well it ain't i'm
sorry to tell you you know it's not
visible or tangible and if you say
there's nothing here because you cannot
see or touch it you're an irrational
individual
okay if you cannot see your touch it's
because you have an irrational
word object
and that would be is if there was a
relay something shooting from the wood
to my finger and my finger to the ground
there me
yeah i mean what we're saying here is
that there is something here if you say
there is nothing here pulling you i know
you didn't hear me you hear me i'm
saying
it could be that whatever is pulling
this to the ground is being relayed
between
it to my hand and my hand to the ground
yeah so it's not that my hand is going
through things
you know it might still be tangible but
it's it's a different mechanism by by
the mechanic by the yeah but there's
still something here yeah yeah but it's
from the wood to my hand and my hand to
the ground so what i'm saying is my hand
isn't going through things and that's in
that theory
okay but all i'm saying is there's
something here you can't see your teeth
there's something here or up here i mean
you can use particles i don't care but
their head better be something something
or down here if you're saying there's
nothing there because you can't see or
touch it first of all you are what was
the idiot is the word if you go to the
lab to try to prove it through some
experiment that's the first one and the
second one is if you do it if you
explain your theory without putting an
object here which is invisible and
intangible you make that assumption
then you're doing it with black magic
you're saying that this
that the earth pulls on this or
something pushes on it uh but there's
nothing there
you're just doing it through black magic
you're through uh what is it
what's it called
action at a distance that's what you're
doing okay
so yeah it's all these people who who
want to do see and touch and again as
well so you seem to be describing the
ropes as if they are physical objects
yeah
yet you also say it's an invisible
medium yeah
how can you say that your mechanism is
direct and physical because physical
means that which has shape
uh these so-called ropes are not visible
again it's the visibility these people
have in their mind if it is a physical
mechanism asking what the rope is made
of or how many ropes there are would
absolutely be a pertinent question no
because they are intangible therefore
you can have gazillions of rope in a
teeny little baby space like that so it
doesn't matter if if they're intangible
if they can't touch each other you can
have many many gazillions of ropes
superimposed which is exactly what
quantum does in its world says that all
these atoms all these particles they
superimpose so there's no difference
there between the official version and
us if you have some other version we'd
like to hear it you know if they don't
superimpose if they're not tangible uh
intangible then i don't know what you
propose instead please propose something
i think to what he's saying in saying he
was confusing
having shape and it being visible how
can something have shape if it is if it
is invisible how do you have an
invisible shape i guess yeah that was
okay and uh the issue is that shape has
nothing to do with visibility yeah
that's the issue the issue is that
tangibility and seeability or visibility
right those are irrational definitions
that mathematicians have used for 3000
years we're saying that's the irrational
definition the correct definition or the
scientific definition is that which has
shape does that mean that you can't can
see it or touch it no because visibility
and tangibility have nothing to do with
shape
the moon had shaped before we were even
here on the planet any human okay so
there was shape already mother nature
deals with that no but it goes to a
deeper issue where it becomes how can i
conceive of something if it is
if if if it has shape but is it is
invisible what we do we give it color
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't mean
like just so we can understand the
theories yeah but the issue here is the
following i can conceptualize to say
like a rope i can imagine a rope i can
see a rope here right this one you can
see and touch and it's got colors etc
right
i don't need that i can imagine one i
can imagine a rope okay so someone says
rope and he doesn't have to show me a
rope because i already know what the
rope word rope means and i imagine okay
i know which i think i know what you're
talking about you're talking about a
braided uh pair of you know the strands
okay and so i i already i don't have to
see it
i already visualize in my head i know
what he's talking about okay in reality
it's invisible yeah we can give it color
in our heads just to so we can
understand each other
we
we have never seen an atom a hydrogen
atom no one has ever on earth seen any
hydrogen atom that's why no one can in
quantum mechanics no one can draw a
hydrogen atom whatever they draw is for
sure irrational and wrong because they
cannot explain why that electron bead
does not spontaneously fly out of the
atom or fall into i mean it just rolls
around or is on different sides of the
proton why why does it fall why does it
run away
and so nobody can draw for you a
hydrogen atom because no one has ever
seen a hydrogen atom does that mean that
a quantum mechanic cannot you know one
of these uh mainstreamers that they
cannot give you a picture of a proton
and an electron next to it in fact
you'll find them all over the internet
look up the word atom and you'll find a
little ball in the center for the
hydrogen atom a little proton in the
center and a lot of bead next to it with
a little circle around it
everybody conceptualizes it so to say
that you cannot have a shape without
having seen it that's irrational your
expectation is irrational okay
okay uh
atoms are not static bowling balls they
are vibrating force fields
a field is a concept so if you say that
a field vibrates it's uh
you know vibrating a force field it's a
force field
may the force go with you that's all i
can say uh anyways we're gonna stop it
here today it's just gone too long today
too much material so we'll see you on
sunday and we'll take somebody i did
want to i thought that was an
interesting question okay it was real
simple last one
a single atom be magnetic
one atom yeah in the universe yeah yeah
in fact um but uh
the best way to answer your question is
to show you
graphically right a a uh little movie of
that and yeah
a single atom can be magnetic and that's
how ionization works but for that i
would love to show you i'll put that on
there if i remember that i'll i'll try
to remember the question
and what i'll do is i'll show you
exactly how ionization works and you'll
see the magnetism how how it's a
magnetic process at the atomic level but
for that i need to show you you know a
picture's worth in fact a movie is worth
a million words that's the way i look
we'll see you next sunday okay coming up
and hopefully